from baslerman
the director who reimagined shakespeare
reinvented the musical
and redefined a classic
comes a bold new vision of an american
but this ain't no nostalgia show
we're gonna do something different
comic book heroes all find their super
powers
elvis found music
uh bring that vase up jerry i wish to
promote you mr president i believe i can
be great
some people wanted to put me in jail so
well's moving down so much as wiggle a
finger
[Applause]
in that moment
elvis the man
was sacrificed
and elvis the god was born
i would do anything to make sure my mama
and daddy never have to live in poverty
ever again
[Music]
colonel you put an end to your boy's
animal behavior or we will
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself
you let me dry and you still want more
i am a promoter that is what i do
what do you say is god-given so there
can't be nothing wrong with it
[Music]
are you ready to fly i'm ready to fly
elvis
friday
[Music]
[Music]
you